e
e e
wow I'm
impressed so now we're going to head
into a Time called uh prayers of the
people and so if those of you who aren't
familiar with this this is a time where
we pray together as a group and uh
there'll be a spot where you can either
audibly or quietly say the name of
someone you're praying for or a
situation uh so join us with this for
this city of saxi Texas and for every
city and community and all who live in
them we pray to you for the Good Earth
you have given us and the wisdom and
will to conserve it we pray to you for
the old and the sick for the Widow and
orphan for the injured and suffering we
pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed
the unemployed and destitute for
prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
[Music]
let the king of my heart be the mountain
where I run the found I drink from oh he
is my S
let the king of my heart be the shadow
where I hide the Rome for my life oh he
is my
soul you are
good
oh you are
oh you are good
good
oh you are
oh let the king of my heart be the wind
inside my SS the anchor in the W oh he
is my
soul let the king of my heart the fire
inside my veins the echo of my days oh
he is
my let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my ve the echo of my days ho is
my soul you are good you're
good oh
oh you are good you're
[Music]
good you are
good
W you are
[Music]
good you're never going to let never
going to let me
down you're you're never going to let
never going to let me
down you're never going to let never
going to let me
[Music]
down you're never going to let never
going to let you're
never you're never going to let never
going to let me
down you're never going to let never
going to let me down cuz you are
good
oh you are
good w
you are
good
wo you are
[Music]
good
you're
let let
[Music]
me you're going to let never going to
let me
down you're never going to let going to
down you're going to
let let me down you are
good
oh you are
[Music]
good no
oh you are
good
[Music]
W how can I respond
to the love that you
have
[Music]
on how can I
respond to the love you
have
[Music]
on I don't have
much I don't have much
I have a heart that beats for you I have
a heart that beats for
[Music]
you to you
like every part of me
[Music]
wants to love you like you L
me my
Lord I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for
you I don't have
much I don't have
but I have a heart thats for I have a
heart thats for I have a heart that
beats for you I have a heart that beats
for you I have a heart thats for you I
have a heart thats for I have a life
I'll give to you I have a life I'll give
to you I have a life I'll give to you I
have a life I'll give to you and I have
a heart that beats for you I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
thats for you I have a heart thats for
you I have a life I'll give to you I
have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give
[Music]
I I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I don't have
much I don't have much
but I have a heart that beats for you I
have a heart that beats for
[Music]
you Lord we come today with that being
our
prayer that we really don't have
much but the heart that you gave us at
Birth is beating for you
we may not have a lot of energy we may
not have fancy
words we really may not have much to
give but our heart is still
[Music]
beating and we know that in our
weakness our times of
struggle that you shine the brightest
so Lord we ask that you would allow us
to be
present calm our stormy
[Music]
Hearts quiet our overthinking
minds and let us rest in
you we ask this in your holy name
amen before you sit down look around and
see if there's anyone you can give an
awkward smile to
[Music]
now yeah okay good evening everybody I'm
Julie Kaiser and I'm here to introduce
our speaker tonight Brett was supposed
to be out on a fun trip um but I think
is home ill instead so um major bummer
for him and that whole crew but I'm
still delighted that we get to have who
we have tonight um cherelle Russell is
um a good friend uh she has a doctorate
Ministry from lipam University and for
the past six years she has been the
pastor of New Heritage Fellowship up in
Allen Fair View is area um she's married
to Tim they have three grown children
who are fantastic um she's an active
participant in the PE in centerpie so
you may have seen her um or she may have
a familiar face to you but I'm delighted
to laugh with her over a drink or to sit
at her feet and listen to her wisdom so
um I hope yall will enjoy shr tonight
all right
testing
testing test test test we'll see we had
it working a little bit
ago test
test test can you hear me now okay well
good evening it's great to be here with
you all um um it's always encouraging to
learn learn that there are other
churches like the one I get to pastor
with in Fairview so I appreciate being
part of this community gathering tonight
and that you're willing to lend me your
ears for 88 minutes just
kidding um no I'm I'm really not
speaking for 88 minutes but Brad did
tell me that I could share a message
that was on my heart and so tonight I'm
going to talk about goodness um I'm also
going to talk about a passage in the
Bible in which we don't always see God's
goodness Matthew 25 the story of the
sheep and the goats and I hope to share
a different and more lifegiving
perspective about that
story so let's talk about goodness the
Hebrew word Tove is the most common word
for good or goodness in the Old
Testament the root of Tove carries
meanings of righteousness generosity and
integrity it is first used in Genesis 1
where God repeatedly declares that
creation is good and ultimately God
calls creation very good Tove Mee this
sets the foundation for Understanding
God's intrinsic goodness and the
goodness that God desires for all of
Creation in the New Testament the Greek
word for good is agathos and it is the
most common term for good and goodness
in the New Testament and it conveys
moral goodness it conveys uprightness
and again the inherent goodness of God
goodness makes it into Paul's lists of
the fruit of the spirit and that makes
sense because if there's one thing that
we can say about God it is that God is
good author Christopher Wright points
out in his book cultivating the fruit of
the spirit that African Christians have
a response they use often when meeting
and greeting one another you might have
heard it God is good all the time all
the time God is good so let's try that
again and I'll start God is good all all
the time God is good God is good and not
in the thin easy way we sometimes use
the word like when we say the weather is
good or dinner was good but in the Deep
steady way that God's goodness runs
beneath all things shaping them toward
love toward
Shalom the psalmist invites us to taste
and see that the Lord is good an
invitation not just to believe in God's
goodness but to experience it to let it
nourish us like bread or to quench our
thirst like living water when Moses
asked God to see God's glory in Exodus
33 God revealed God's goodness as
Central to who God
is I
will
that is that better hear
me you want me to use that
is that
good this might seem awkward to you all
but it's not at nhf we always say we're
High participation and low Perfection so
this is great this makes me feel at home
and um I'm always appreciative of tech
because to me it's the hardest thing to
do at
church all right so I'll go back to
Moses
when Moses asked God to see God's glory
in Exodus 33 God revealed God's goodness
as Central to who God is God said I will
cause my goodness to pass in front of
you and I will Proclaim my name the Lord
in your presence but the goodness of God
is not always what we expect we might
look for it in grand miracles in
triumphant victories in the sweet
certainty of a life without hardship but
scripture tells another story it speaks
of a god whose goodness is often hidden
in the most unlikely places in
Wilderness wonderings in exile's longing
in a Widow's might in the cries of the
Brokenhearted the prophets remind us
that God is good not because we are
always rescued from our suffering but
because we are never abandoned in
it for the Lord is good Psalm 105 says
God's love endures forever God's
faithfulness continues through all
generations and then we come to Jesus
and we experience the very embodiment of
God's goodness in flesh and Bone when
the Rich Young Ruler calls him good
teacher Jesus answers why do you call me
good no one is good except for God
Alone Jesus is not denying his own
goodness here he's rooting it in the
very nature of God in John 10:11 Jesus
says I am the Good Shepherd the Good
Shepherd lays down his life for the
Sheep Jesus doesn't just possess
goodness he embodies it showing
self-giving and self-sacrificial love
and in Acts the ministry of Jesus is
summed up well in chapter
10:38 it says God anointed Jesus of
Nazareth with the Holy Spirit and power
and he went around doing what good
healing all who were under the power of
the devil because God was with him
Jesus's Ministry was a direct outpouring
of God's goodness demonstrated in
healing and deliverance and compassion
passion Jesus shows us what divine
goodness looks like it looks like
Healing The Sick it looks like welcoming
the outcast speaking truth to power boy
do we need that one today and breaking
bread with Sinners it looks like laying
down his life pouring himself out so
that the world might know and
participate in the fullness of
God and according to Paul what is the
antidote to evil in this
world goodness Romans 12:21 says do not
be overcome by evil but overcome evil
with good the power of goodness to
overcome evil is at the heart of the
gospel and the way of Jesus Paul exhorts
us not to be consumed by the darkness
around us but to actively counter it
with the light of goodness with Tove
this is not a passive or a naive
optimism it's a defiant and courageous
choice to reflect God's character in a
world that so often seems bent towards
selfishness and
Injustice goodness has a transformative
power because it refuses to play by the
roles of the powers and principalities
of this world Jesus embodied this when
he responded to hatred with love
to violence with sacrifice and to
betrayal with forgiveness the cross
itself is the ultimate example of
overcoming evil with good not by
overpowering force but by absorbing its
worst and rising in Victorious and
Abiding Love when we choose goodness in
our daily lives by extending kindness
where there is cruelty offering truth
where there is deception and pursuing
Justice where there is oppression we
participate in God's Redemptive work
showing that light is stronger than
darkness and that goodness that Tove
that the goodness of God in the end will
prevail all right so now let's talk
about this Troublesome text Matthew 25
31-46 our church has been dwelling in
this passage for six weeks and it has
caused some Lively and troubling
conversation Among Us lots of questions
Confusion And even concern feel free to
take out your digital Scrolls and look
up the passage I'm reading from the NIV
if you want to look that up 20 Matthew
25: 31-
46 when the son of man comes in his
glory and all the angels with him him he
will sit on his glorious Throne all the
nations will be gathered before him and
he will separate the people one from
another as a Shepherd separates the
sheep from the goats he will put the
sheep on his right and the goats on his
left then the king will say to those on
his right come you who are blessed by my
father take your inheritance the kingdom
prepared for you since the creation of
the world for I was hungry and you gave
me something to eat I was thirsty and
you gave me something to drink I was a
stranger and you invited me in I needed
clothes and you clothed me I was sick
and you looked after me I was in prison
and you came to visit me then the
righteous will answer himl when did we
see you hungry and feed you or thirsty
and give you something to drink when did
we see you a stranger and invite you in
or needing clothes and clothe you when
did we see you sick or in prison and go
to visit you and the King will reply
truly I tell you whatever you did for
one of the least of these brothers and
sisters of mine you did for me then he
will say to those on his left depart
from me you who are cursed into the
Eternal fire prepared for the devil and
his angels for I was hungry and you gave
me nothing to eat I was thirsty and you
gave me nothing to drink I was a
stranger and you did not invite me in I
needed clothes and you did not clothe me
I was sick and in prison and you did not
look after me they also will answer Lord
when did we see you hungry or thirsty or
a stranger or needing clothes or sick or
in prison and did not help you and he
reply truly I tell you whatever you did
not do for one of the least of these you
did not do for me
then they will go away to Eternal
punishment but the righteous to eternal
life so I come preach for the first time
and I bring this
text one of our members today said I
can't even read some of those lines I
don't even want to say them out loud um
and I think a lot of us if you've grown
up in the church you've seen verses like
this used to hurt people deeply and so
my hope this evening is to cast a
different Vision with this
text when the son of man comes in glory
the story says he will gather all the
nations before him and in that moment
Like a Shepherd sorting sheep from goats
he will separate them not by their
beliefs not by their Church attendance
not my by how many Bible verses that
they can recite but by something much
simil temp did they feed the
hungry did they welcome The
Stranger did they visit the sick and
imprisoned several years ago I used to
write a blog you won't be able to find
it I deleted it thankfully I used to
write about something I called surprise
theology surprise theology was theology
that entailed me learning something new
or surprising about God Jesus the Holy
Spirit the church church or the Bible
and there are a lot of surprises in the
Bible I still find them and I still
mostly love when I find surprises in the
Bible I think surprise theology fits
well in post- Evangelical communities
because we tend to welcome the process
of both deconstruction and
reconstruction because we tend to
welcome the teaching to be new wine
skins ready for new wine and because we
tend to want to pursue good theology
together so I think Matthew 25 would fit
in my old surprise theology
blog I don't know about your experience
with this passage but in my experience M
much of the focus has usually been on
the Sorting of the sheep judgment and
Punishment and that understandably might
make us uncomfortable it certainly has
been one of the questions we have
wrestled with at nhf several things in
this story would have surprised
Matthew's audience some would have
surprised his disciples and some are
surprising to US unless we're very
familiar with how common this kind of
apocalyptic literature was at the
time I actually don't think that this
passage is about judgment and Punishment
I don't think that's the heart of the
message the things that Jesus said to
his disciples before he died were very
intentional and
important I wonder if what we do with
this passage is what we've done with
many of Jesus's teachings we
automatically try to figure out which
group we're in am I a sheep or a goat
and then we start trying to figure out
what group other people are in are they
a sheep or a goat does that sound
familiar but here's the part we often
miss here's the Sur
surprise notice that both groups are
confused neither saw the son of man the
king in the faces of those they helped
or ignored but those PR both those
praised for caring for the king and
those admonished for not caring for the
king respond with the same measure of
confusion both say Lord when did we see
you hungry when did we see you thirsty
when did we see you a stranger or
needing clothes when did we see you sick
or in
prison Jesus says that both groups are
surprised by what the son of man the
king says why because neither expected
the son the king who comes in glory to
be present and available to them in the
faces of the least of these neither
expected to find God's goodness there
but both groups imagined that the son of
man the king would come in strength and
power and might and glory and yet Jesus
in this Parable and in the days to come
during his arrest and crucifixion
reveals that his goodness comes to us in
weakness in vulnerability and even in
Brokenness as it turns out none of them
not the goats nor the Sheep had eyes
eyes to see and ears to hear and this
fits with Matthew's depiction of the
disciples very gradually coming to
understand Jesus's identity but not
without confusion fear and resistance
and this also fits with Matthew's
overall trajectory of transformation for
those who follow Jesus
surprise Jesus insists that his kingdom
his goodness is hidden in the places we
often
Overlook Jesus the king does not just
wait for us in Heaven's High halls but
meets Us in the long lines at the food
pantry in the quiet of a hospital room
in the prison visitation area among the
displaced and weary and in the prayers
of those who wonder if God still
hears Jesus wants his disciples to know
before he leaves that he is and will be
present always in the faces and needs of
their
neighbors surprise in showing up for one
another for those in need we find
ourselves ushered into the Kingdom's
goodness right where we are this is not
the god that the disciples expected but
it is the god that they got what do we
expect where will we look for God's
goodness I hope that we will see it in
ourselves and in those around us two
points before I
close God's goodness is not passive we
reflect God's goodness by participating
in Acts of Love mercy and Justice as we
follow Jesus we might find that living
as conduits of God's goodness becomes
second nature in Luke 6 vers 43 through
45 Jesus makes the connection between
Our Roots and our fruits
he says no good tree Bears Bad fruit nor
does a bad tree bear good fruit each
tree is recognized by its own fruit
people do not pick figs from Thorn
bushes or grapes from Briars a good man
brings good things out of the good
stored up in his heart and an evil man
brings evil things out of the evil
stored up in his heart for the mouth
speaks what the heart is full of and
here's the second point
goodness is a measure of a life well
lived good people perhaps Jesus is
inviting us to reflect on better
questions and in our journey with him
not if we have the best theological
arguments or if we built the best and
biggest churches or if we gain some kind
of worldly success Jesus asks will you
love will you care will you embody my
Tove my goodness in the
world and so one more time God is
good all the time God is good I'll say a
prayer and then I've been instructed to
welcome you to the table so I'll do
that let's
pray God we ask that you would cause all
your goodness to pass before us please
open our eyes to see you where you have
always been right in front of us in the
faces of our neighbor in the faces of
those who hunger and thirst in the eyes
of the Lonely may we love as you love
not because we expect a reward but
because your kingdom is made real in the
giving and receiving of
Mercy may this church be a place of Tove
a community of Truth love Justice and
goodness that reflects your heart
amen and now we're going to participate
in communion and this is the blessing
that Brett gave me and I love it so I
hope I'll do it
justice uh where's the table right here
this is the table not of the church but
of the Lord It's Made ready for those
who love him and for those who want to
love him more so come you who have much
faith and you who have have little you
who have been here often and you who
have not been here for long you who have
tried to follow and you who have failed
come because it's the Lord Jesus who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
there come to the table
[Music]
well
I'm always really
encouraged uh when a song Just ma
matches the message so well without any
planning uh the song we're going to end
with today is called someday
soon and it has become a very special
important song to a lot of us up here
and so I encourage you to just sit and
uh sit with the lyric
see see what might jump out to you and
uh watch the Lord connect the dots
between the lyrics and uh the beautiful
message that was just
given there is a shadow in the
hallway trying to frighten you don't let
the
darkness surround you
you can make it
[Music]
through don't you give up on the
kingdom think it's crashing in no it
ain't worth all the
worry they'll still let you in
[Music]
some days soon these worries
roll
soon sometimes the
weight of decisions
[Music]
try to BU you don't let the
shame tell you
something that you know ain't
true just cuz you
feel like a
stranger that don't mean you
are God I could use a
[Music]
reminder what forgiveness is
foray soon these worries roll
[Music]
on soon
some
days these
[Music]
worries
soon sometimes the cold wind
blows sometimes the w
Rush don't think the
batt over just cuz they say
[Music]
Amen sometimes the cold wind
blows sometimes the W
rushing don't think the better
over just they say
am some days soon these worries roll
on
St day soon
[Music]
soon these
worries some days
[Music]
soon
somay
soon in enough oh
[Music]
thank you thank you praise team I was
going to say and thank you Pastor we
enjoyed that that
message um I forgot an announcement and
I'm going to say it now we will have a
child dedication ceremony at our church
service um one week from today Sunday
March 2nd uh if you have a young
children who are not yet ready to be
baptized and you would like to commit to
raising them in a way of Jesus then
please sign up to participate uh in that
time by scanning the QR
code we want to thank you so much for
joining us this evening if you are new
and would we would love for you to fill
out a card at the little table on your
way out or just scan the QR code on the
screens to fill out the online visitor
card generosity is a key aspect of
adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan the QR code or
visit the TBL tx.org
we can all use a little more emotional
and relational support and spiritual
connection the way that we do that at
the table is through our meetups if you
are not yet part of a Meetup please scan
the QR code to find out what works for
you all right let me send you into your
week with this
blessing you can hold your hands out in
a posture to receive or just open your
hearts to these
words you are a child of
God
you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
this is true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead of
it's yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between go filled with
the assurance that you are
loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
be
blessed have a good
week and we hope to see you back here
next Sunday good
[Music]
night
somay soon these wores
[Music]
some days soon